-Thank you for doing
this Christmas movie different.
I appreciate you doing that.
We hung out all day together.
-How fun with that?
-It was the greatest.
We always -- We --
-Two-take maximum.
[ Laughter ]
Two-take maximum.
-We nailed it!
We had some good takes.
It was so much fun.
Happy holidays to you and --
and your family.
-You too.
-I'm happy to see you in person.
Thanks for making the trip
and being here.
-Absolutely.
-Well, what are your --
Do you have, like,
family traditions?
Do you have holiday plans?
What do you have coming up?
-This year, we're gonna get
all the McConaughey family.
We're also getting
Camila's family.
So when we do that --
When we have that
multicultural Christmas,
Christmas lasts a long time
at our place.
Because they celebrate
on the 24th.
Midnight, you exchange presents,
all right?
So you have
the big sit-down dinner.
You get the china out
for the first time all year.
[ Laughter ]
If it was up to my family,
it'd be paper plates.
Thank you, Camila.
[ Laughter ]
-Get the china out.
-A better ritual.
-"No, we are using china."
-Yes.
-Thank you, Camila, yeah.
-And then we do that that night,
and then we get up the next day,
and we do our Christmas,
which is everyone
opens presents, Santa came.
The problem, the reason I say
it's longer already,
is that my mother, who's 90,
still demands that you --
everyone open their present,
and everyone watch one person
open their present at a time.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-If you got a big
Brazilian family, you got a big
McConaughey family.
There's a family of 20.
There's a lot of presents,
thankfully.
-Yes.
-It may be dark on the 25th
when we're done opening presents
from that morning.
And so, it's 7:00 p.m.,
and you just finished
opening presents
from Christmas morning.
-Yeah.
-So the nights get long.
-My grandma used to do this
thing where we'd unwrap
the presents, she goes,
"Can you just not rip it
just so I could reuse
the wrapping?"
[ Laughter ]
-Save the wrapping.
-Save the wrap
for the next year.
I go, "Yes, okay, Grandma."
-It's 3:00 p.m.
-"All right, let's go!
Let's open up the thing," yeah.
It's so fun.
I look forward to it.
Do you -- Are you a guy that
makes New Year's resolutions?
-Eh...
[ Laughter ]
I check in on myself.
-You check in on yourself, yeah.
-You know, I ask -- I ask --
I ask myself
to work on my patience
last year.
-Yeah.
-On New Year's Eve.
-We all need to do that.
-And I'm --
Now thank you for reminding me.
I guess tonight,
I'll start thinking about how
I've done the last 11 months.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, exactly right.
Well, I think the last time
we talked --
I mean, congratulations.
Your book, "Greenlights"...
-Yeah.
-...was on "The New York Times"
best-seller list.
[ Cheers and applause ]
50, 5-0.
-Yeah.
-50 weeks, it sold like
2.5 million copies.
It is a giant, giant hit, bud.
Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-I loved it.
-Did you -- Did you realize
it would take off like that?
I mean, so many people --
-I had no idea.
-It's massive.
-I -- It -- it hit a nerve.
-Yeah.
-Thank you, everyone out there
who had already read it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was so honest,
and it was so --
I loved it.
I told you as soon as I read it,
I couldn't stop reading it.
I go, "Oh, this is so --
it's so personal,
but it's so, also, universal."
-Yeah. I think that's what
people got from it.
People said,
"Hey, I see myself in you.
I see my stories
in your stories."
It kind of lays out a map,
a process.
It's a process book.
It is not a product book.
It's an approach to life
with this rodeo we're all
trying to get through
and trying to get
our 8 seconds on.
-Yeah. "Greenlights" --
-How can we --
how can we do our best
to get it?
-You -- Actually, you're --
you're coming out with a --
a journal now,
a companion journal,
to help people because I --
I think you were saying
in the book, too.
It's tough when you write --
to just tell someone,
"Hey, just write something down
every day or every night."
-A blank sheet of paper
intimidates the heck out of us,
right?
-It does.
-But journaling
or writing things down,
I've done it all my life,
and it's how I wrote
"Greenlights," the book.
Immensely valuable.
I mean,
I write things down to forget.
If you write them down,
you can forget them
'cause they're in there.
[ Laughter ]
Don't just go to the diary
or the journal to write down
when your frustrated
and confused.
Go to the journal to write down
what you're doing in life
when you're rolling,
when you're catching
green lights,
when you're in the flow,
because we will
get out of flow again.
And it's nice to have a document
to back and go, "Whew!
What was I doing when I was --
when I was cruising?"
-Yeah, when life was perfect.
-You know, you see habits and
you can change and recalibrate.
But, yeah, it's a journal.
I got little nudges
along the way to kind of help
you and ask you some questions,
to write your story.
-Yeah.
-The book of "Greenlights"
was my story.
This is for your story.
-Yeah, I love that, buddy.
That's awesome.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Congrats on that.
-Thank you.
-We also -- You were nice enough
to Zoom into us
when we couldn't
get any guests anywhere.
No one was allowed
to travel or do anything.
But there was talk of you maybe
running for governor of Texas.
-Right.
-And you recently decided
to not run for governor.
-Yes.
-Can you walk us
through that decision?
-Whew!
Well, it was a two-year
consideration that I came
to the decision, really,
over the last couple of months.
And I was asking myself
the original question
and trying to answer,
"How and where and what can I do
to be most useful to myself,
to my family, and to
the most amount of people?"
The embassy, the category
of politics came up,
and it's a privileged one that
I gave great consideration to.
But at this point in my life,
with the things --
I've got a 13-year-old,
an 11-year-old, an 8-year-old --
the life I'm living right now,
the storytelling
I want to keep doing,
it's not the category for me
at this point in my life.
-Still not ruling out future?
-I'm not until I am.
-Okay.
-Someone told me that was
a very McConaughey answer
the other day.
[ Laughter ]
-"I'm not until I am."
It's very -- yeah.
Yeah, that is.
-I'll be keeping
an eye open for --
-Because I know --
you know, Texas loves you.
And when we -- when we did
the show from Texas,
you were nice enough
to come on the show.
And, gosh, you're beloved
down there, as well.
You think people love you here,
standing ovations,
they love you there.
-It's a great state.
-I know you put on a benefit
concert with your wife...
-Yeah.
-...called "We're Texas."
-After that rough,
awful winter storm.
-Winter storm Uri came through.
We're not used to winter storms
like that in Texas, okay?
-No.
-We -- We were a bit awkward.
We weren't prepared, and a lot
of people were out of home.
A lot of people
were out of school.
A lot of people needed some help
because they didn't --
they didn't
know how to deal with it.
And so, my foundation, which is
the just keep livin Foundation,
we got together and said,
"We're not disaster relief,
but want to be disaster relief?"
We said, "Let's go."
And I headed to Texas.
I got on the phone.
Camila got on the phone.
100% of the people we called,
whether it was companies
who donated, whether it was
musicians who came in,
everybody was a "yes."
And the first 30 seconds,
we went down to Texas,
put the show on,
and we raised over $7.7 million.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's how you do it
right there.
You just stepped up, and I go,
"Oh, my gosh.
What do you know about
putting on a live concert?"
You're like, "Nothing."
-It was, like, two takes today.
You get -- No, you get one take.
You know, two maximum,
but let's throw it together
because you have to --
disaster relief,
you have to move quickly,
because if you take your time
to say,
"Oh, this has
got to be perfect,"
something else is taking
the front-page news.
There's another disaster coming.
You know?
So you need --
you need to jump on it quickly
and get everyone together
and take advantage
of trying to get people to give
at that time
when it is front-page news
and they know people need help.
-I saw "Hollywood Reporter"
gave you --
named you
Philanthropist of the Year
for all the stuff
you do to give back.
-That was cool.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's good.
It's good to be,
but it's also great
to give back.
And it's also -- it's great.
You know what you do?
You -- You show up.
Every time, you always show up,
for me, but I think
for anything.
I know you're a great dad.
-Well, thank you.
Try to.
I think we all try to.
You know, I think we -- we learn
more and more as we age.
We serve ourself
when we do serve others.
That is a reciproc--
little exchange right there.
-Yeah.
-And then, also, there's ways
to serve ourself and serve
others at the same time.
And where those two meet
when we're filling
our bank account and our souls
account at the same time,
we're getting the quantity and
the quality at the same time...
-Yeah.
-Honeyhole.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's what I'm talking about.
I want to talk about
and show a clip from "Sing 2."
More with Matthew McConaughey
when we come back, everybody.
Come on back.
[ Cheers and applause ]